c'est vrai que c'était un rêve pour vous
parce que c'est vrai que l'émission
cartonne vous êtes les stars la femme
pays sart de l'émission et c'est vrai
que depuis quelques jours c'est devenu
un cauchemar et vous avez reçu je vais
dire un laïc ya quinze jours vous avez
reçu une lettre dans votre boîte dans
laquelle on insulte votre famille et
vous même alors j'ai le contenu de la
lettre
espèce de saloperies
dagen botoxée tu ressembles à ce que tu
es voilà où il ya des morales s'est même
pas envie de dire parce que c'est vrai
tu es une honte pour les familles
nombreuses c'est alors si il ya des
franchement regardez regardez c'est
vraiment voilà vomir de slavomir les
grands et les petits il parle de vos
enfants aussi
regardez voilà c'est sait vraiment si on
va vous laisser dire parce que j'ai même
pas envie de dire ça
vous avez vous avez reçu ça c'est une
première lettre vous en avez reçu une
deuxième après c'est que t'es quoi votre
action
on en avait déjà reçu une première un
peu plus d'un an
un peu dans le même registre mais plus
axé sur moi dans l'accord vraiment dans
le but de me dénigrer moi pas tellement
mes enfants
après le contenu de cette lettre là
qu'on voit c'est ni plus ni mois ce
qu'on voit tous les jours sur les
réseaux sociaux les nîmois en fait oui a
rien qui me met une lettre une les voilà
c'est
ça oui là le problème c'est que ce
contenu est arrivé dans ma boîte aux
lettres avec mon adresse mon nom de
jeune fille en plus sûres c'est vrai que
valérie benaïm l'enquêtrice ne tapez a
dit oui c'est vrai que c'est latine et à
l'adresse
que les réseaux sociaux voilà et et donc
vous avez reçu un cd vous avez porté
plainte alors après cette première
lettre on a voulu porter plainte la
police a refusé cette plainte et nous a
envoyé qu'une main courante d'accord
pensant que ce n'était pas suffisant
c'est passé lourd en fait pour ça ne
justifiait pas une plainte simplement
une main courante au kazoo se passerait
quelque chose et si on recevait une
deuxième lettre on pouvait la déposer
plainte ce serait légitime alors une
semaine plus tard vous recevez une
deuxième lettre
cette fois-ci adresser à votre mari
alexandre je m'adresse à vous alexandre
pélissard quand vous pouvez supporter la
vie avec votre pouvoir voilà deux pays
tu eu de femme amandine en ce moment
elle est à paris et h et chaque fois que
mode training [ __ ] elle vous trompe
nous avons des preuves et photos qui
seront mis sur instagram nous avons eu
son père biologique et les mentions skid
row dit sur sa vie comme quoi elle a été
abusée c'est faux soyez indulgents
alexandre vous êtes à mon papa ça va
faire la une des journaux bon courage
c'est
pour ça que c'est ça même personne
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est la même
personne ou alors c'est pas la même main
qui a écrit la lettre ça c'est sûr on a
bien examiné l'écriture les tampons les
codes à poser à l' enveloppe par les
machines d'oblitération de la poste
c'est pas la même personne après c'est
pas exclu que ce soit mais vous pensez
pas que ce sont des duos et le voisinage
ou ces deux mois c'est la jalousie je le
vois comme ça moi je le vois je vois ça
c'est quelqu'un qui vous connaît pas
exception ça c'est quelqu'un qui est
dans le voisinage jill ci parce qu'en
plus amandine a fait une vraie enquête
avec l'oblitération sur l' enveloppe et
vous avez déterminé que ça ne venait pas
de loin
la partie revient très certainement de
quelqu'un de là où vous habitez et qui
vous connaît bien c'est ça qui fait
encore plus peur je suis vous avez une
idée la première enveloppe effectivement
le code le code le code 33 et le code de
ceux du centre distribution est plus
proche de nos domisiel donc
effectivement en tout cas la première
enveloppe ans et qu'elle a pas été posté
- si on peut envoyer quelqu'un de lille
où d'ailleurs posté une enveloppe
le canon ça veut rien dire manon tard à
paris un six classes et dont ils
attendent alors juste vous avez une idée
du tout les classes étaient postés pas
loin vous avez une idée car ça peut être
absolument pas n'ont aucune idée ah non
on a beaucoup de donateurs ça on a beau
corps personnes qui nous dézingue depuis
le premier jour et nous encore plus que
les autres familles en fait le premier
jour nous on a été on a fait très
critiquée donc c'est vrai qu'on est très
hermétique à tout ce qui se dit sur les
réseaux en fait parce que moi j'essaie
de voir le toujours le verre à moitié
plein je sais je sais ce que vaut ma
famille je sais ce qu'ils sont pour moi
est ce que je suis pour eux ça c'est
notre force après effectivement que ça
dépasse les réseaux là par contre c'est
là le problème